قام دكتاتور كوريا الشمالية المتقلب
بتصعيد سلوكه العدواني مؤخرًا ، حيث
أجرى سبعة اختبارات صاروخية على الأقل
في الأسبوعين الماضيين ، بما في ذلك
واحدة أرسلت صاروخًا مباشرة فوق اليابان.
قد تكون محاولة إعادة الولايات المتحدة
إلى طاولة المفاوضات بطريقة أكثر
إلحاحًا ، ربما يقترحون الآن
أنه على الرغم من أنهم يقولون
إنهم لا يريدون أي نوع من الحوار ،
فإنهم على استعداد لقبول العروض
من  الولايات المتحدة من الولايات المتحدة من
كوريا الجنوبية واليابان ردًا عدوانيًا
من جانبهم على تجارب صاروخية التي أجراها كيم ،
حيث أجرى الحلفاء تدريبات عسكرية مشتركة
لإطلاق تجارب صاروخية
، وفي خطوة تصفها السلطات الكورية الجنوبية
بأنها غير عادية للغاية ، أعادت الولايات المتحدة نشر
حاملة طائرات في المياه
قبالة  شبه الجزيرة الكورية فعلوا ما
كان عليهم فعله ، لكنهم لم يكونوا كافيين
لردع كوريا الشمالية ، وأعتقد أن أحدث
اختبار صاروخي هو مجرد مقدمة
ما هو ما
سيحدث وسيكون هناك تجربة نووية سابعة
ربما تكون اختبارًا لسلاح نووي تكتيكي
يقول المحللون أنه من المرجح أن يأتي في المستقبل القريب
نظام كيم لم يجر تجربة واحدة في
خمس سنوات  لكن يبدو الآن أن لديه
Swagger جديدًا لإطلاق واحد على الأقل مؤخرًا
، ظهر في سترة بيضاء مع
بنطلون أسود في وقت من الأوقات ارتدى ما
بدا وكأنه قبعة سفاري كاكي بينما كان
يحدق من خلال مناظير مثبتة في
حدث آخر ارتدى المرشد الأعلى
سترة الميدان البني بينما كان يحاول تغطية
أذنيه ، أظهر أنه
جريء وفخور وأنه متورط في
هذا وأن برنامج الأسلحة النووية التكتيكي
يتبع
فكرته في العلاقات بينما كان كيم
يغازل الرئيس السابق ترامب ، لقد وقعنا
في الحب و  بعد فترة هدوء في الاختبارات
أثناء الوباء الطمع ، عاد كيم
إلى السلوك المتشدد الصريح الذي
جعله يمثل تهديدًا في المقام الأول ولكن مع
بعض الروايات المشؤومة الأخيرة.  في وقت سابق من هذا
العام ،
هدد كيم وشقيقته الصغرى المتزايدة النفوذ كيم يو جونغ
بإبادة كوريا الجنوبية
بضربات نووية استباقية إذا شعروا بالتهديد.
لقد خرج كتاب Playbook وكوريا الشمالية
حرفيًا للتو بمبدأ نووي
حيث خفضوا
عتبة الاستخدام الوقائي للأسلحة النووية